Welcome to lesson two. In the last lesson, you created
an app that tracked the very basic elements in a
music festival. Before we talk about what we're going to learn
in this lesson, you're going to hang out with Samantha and
Andy in a real music festival, and get a better
idea what exactly what your app needs to do. There
were just so many things going on, I mean obviously
there are the bands, and the stages, and the attendees.
>> And lots of stuff.
Food, drink vendors, but there were some unexpected things too.
>> I really liked the view from the Ferris Wheel. That was pretty cool.
>> Definitely, and then the silent disco is awesome.
>> Oh my goodness taking off those headphones, and
then not being able to hear the music anymore.
>> Yeah. That was like trippy.
>> Very surreal.
>> The bubble guy.
>> That was super cool, and the alien parade.
>> There are those ladies on stilts who you refused to dance with.
>> Look, I don't have as much rhythm as you okay, Andy?
>> Alright, so it's safe to
say there's a lot going on, but despite all
the chaos, the festival overall was pretty well organized.
>> And yeah, we were able to find our way around the festival to make it
to the right stages at the right times, and see the bands we wanted to see.